C'est pas ce que vous croyez... Les amis j'ai vécu un vrai... traumatisme...
Et je le dis avec la voix du mec qui est vraiment traumatisé
Ça ne veut pas dire que je ne le suis pas vraiment parce que je l'ai dit avec la voix du mec donc vous pouvez pas sav.. hé ho t'insinues pas que je mens
Laissez moi vous expliquer...
Pour prendre l'histoire du début, ces derniers jours j'ai eu un petit délire je me suis dit:
"Putain un test de QI ça ressemble à quoi déjà? Je me souviens plus j'en avais fait un j'avais 6 ans"
Et je me souvenais plus de quoi c'était fait et de combien de QI j'avais
ça me faisait marrer de refaire ça. Je tape alors "test de QI"
Sur Google, et c'est la pire chose à faire
j'suis très con, des fois sur internet j'ai le même comportement qu'une personne de 50 ans
C'est fou... Donc je clique sur un lien,
je fais un test et tout ils t'expliquent:
ça va se passer comme ça, il va y avoir des questions, t'auras 1 min pour répondre à chaque questions
Il y aura un total de 50 questions... blablabla BREF pendant 1 heure
Je fais ce putain de test là, j'arrive à la fin, je me dis "franchement j'ai géré"
"Le QI va être bien et tout"
"Put*** je m'aime"
Et je voulais me suc** comme ça
Et là,
Je clique sur voir mes résultats, Qu'est-ce que qu'il se passe, à ce moment-là?
Bah déjà il y a une nouvelle page qui charge et tout,
Et là, ils disent "Merci de rentrer 4 code allopass
Pour avoir vos résultats"
Et là tu ressens vraiment la même chose que quand on kidnappe ton enfant comme ça
on lui retire les bras et les jambes
Et on te le rend, si t'envoies un Allopass.
C'est alors que j'ai pris mon sifflet à seins comme ça et j'ai fait *bruit du Sifflet* NON!
J'ai préféré perdre une heure de temps de ma vie plutôt que de perdre 3 euros
Pour des encul** d'escrocs!
Bref ça c'est l'anecdote qui ne sert à rien
Mais après je suis tombé sur un site très très bien qui s'appelle "Mon-QI.com"
Pourquoi je vous parle de ça aujourd'hui?
Parce que, bon il y a des tests pour faire son QI bla bla bla
mais il y a des tests qui n'ont rien avoir avec le QI
et qui sont très intéressants et qui t'enrichissent vraiment
en terme de mécanique de cerveau
et de culture, hein
regardez ça, c'est fantastique: test psychotechnique:
tu as des tests de logique, de carte, de mathématique, de mémoire, mécanique, de verbal et de dominos.
ça c'est le test de QI, donc tu en as plusieurs, hein.
Il y a plusieurs tests de QI disponibles et chaque test se présente sous la forme de 30 questions,
et tu as à chaque fois un temps limité pour répondre à chaque question.
Moi j'adore tout ce qui est maths, calcul mental, logique, j'adore ça.
Mais avec le temps, depuis que je ne vais plus à l'école,
j'ai eu mon BAC, je perds du niveau en orthographe,
en conjugaison, en grammaire je perd vraiment du niveau. Et ça me fait chier
du coup, on va faire ensemble un test de vocabulaire, plus précisément
un test de synonyme, quel est le synonyme de Circonstance ?
Ok!
"allure - expérience - disconvenance - conjoncture - prévoyant - je ne sais pas"
et ben mec ce qu'on va faire, c'est simple, on va tout simplement rentabiliser ce dictionnaire
que j'avais acheté pour la vidéo avec Bigflo et Oli
*Rire*
Donc les circonstances, mec je sais pas, je dirais que c'est conjoncture
aaaaaah c'est horrible cette vidéo parce que soit j'ai bon à tout
et tout le monde s'en bat les couilles, soit j'ai faux à des trucs bateau comme là
et là par contre, je suis vraiment humilié, je passe pour le bon con de YouTube
Quel est le synonyme de Apprécier, bah ça on sait, ça va
savourer - réunir - comprendre - régler - motiver. aller savourer. salut
le synonyme de prudence : distraction - absence - amusement - négligence - vigilance
ben c'est bien évidemment la vigilance.  le synonyme de Sacrilège
mot que je n'avais pas entendu depuis 2002
Hérésie - avenant - je m'en bat les couille, petit robert, c'est le joker, je m'en bats les couilles
avenant, dis moi qu'Alain Rey l'a mis dans le petit Robert
Dis moi que tu l'as mis Alain! "avenant" YES! merci Alain Rey je t'aime
*lit la définition* "Qui plaît par son bon air, sa bonne grâce
ah merde je viens de voir le synonyme c'était affable
Mais de toute façon je le savais j'allais le dire
C'était une petit test voir si Alain Rey avait pensé à tout
Suivant
Frasque!
Mec, c'est chaud là hein...
C'est une frasque remarquable, c'est une oeuvre...
Une frasque c'est peut-être une oeuvre
non frasque c'est trop gras et moche pour que ça soit une oeuvre
Voilà on est exactement ce que je vous disait tout-à-l'heure
Je pue la merde en grammaire c'est terrible
Synonyme de : SUBTERFUGE
Ah il a mis au point un subterfuge pour s'échapper de la cage
Je dirais échappatoire
Ok je valide combien j'ai !?
8/10? (Cri de joie)
J'ai eu de la chance, j'ai eu de la chance comme au bac C'est Sure
Ah lors là je me suis tromper c'était pour délétère ça veut pas dire salubre ça veut dire toxique!
Et frasque c’était pas oeuvre mais incartade
Une incartade c'est une écart de conduit mais oui! il a fait une frasque
Bref vous voyez parfaitement ce qui se passe
Sur ce site mon-QI.com
test verbal ça c'est le piiiiire
Regarder,alors dans les tests verbaux l'autre catégorie qui était cool c’était le genre, mec
Dès fois il y a des mots tu ne sais pas du tout si c'est masculin ou féminin
Alors que tu les utilises dans la vie courante
Par exemple on dit un aérogare ou une aérogare? on dit une gare pourquoi on dirait un aérogare
Je sais pourquoi je me répond à moi même, Qu'est ce qui se passe ? je vous coupe la parole je m'en fou
On dit un aéroport mais on dit une gare
Du coup on dit un ou une aérogare ?
ce que je viens de faire ça ferait une très très bonne annonce YouTube, tu sais quand tu dois
divertir en 5 secondes, avant que le mec clique sur ignorer l'annonce fils de p**e
Eh ben là il ignorait pas,j'ai trouvé on dit un port ( de bateau) et un aéroport Donc si on dit
Une Gare on dit une aérogare BIMMM
C'est sur c'est bon, Alors un aphte ou une aphte?
C'est un aphte
Non ça à un moment faut pas me prendre pour un
Un Mousiquaire ou une moustiquaire, nan mais quand même!
Quand même, Un échappatoire fiscal ou une échappatoire fiscale
Un Gérard Depardieu ou une Gérard Depardieu
Un échappatoire je dirais
Un tentacule ou une tentacule
Alors c'est un tentacule
je crois que le terme scientifique c'est du masculin
sur tentacule, alors un obélisque ou une obélisque, c'est une obélisque
Alors Combien j'ai ? 8/10 PUT*** MAIS LE MEC s'accroche au 8/10, Put***
Hey Je suis pas si nul, Alors malheureusement c’était pas un échappatoire fiscale
Mais c'était une échappatoire fiscale
Payant tous mes impôts en France je ne savais pas il est vrai, c'est un obélisque? Mec j'adore
Les soir j'en fait 3,4 Comme ça d'affiler ça m'amuse énormément
Celui qui est bien c'est les proverbe Mec c'est fou alors ça c'est fou
En gros ils nous donne un Proverbe et il faut trouver dans une liste de plusieurs proverbe, celui qui a le sens le plus Proche
Vous allez voir mec ya des proverbe c'est de la folie
C'est irréaliste c'est de la science fiction
Donc 'rira bien qui rira le dernier'
Quelle proverbe a le même sens
'la vengeance est un plat qui se mange froid'
'On n'est jamais puni pour avoir fait mourir de dire'
Si un ami à vous, vous dit ça il faut vraiment s'en débarrasser
Il ne faut plus que ça soit votre ami
'Bien dire fait rire, Bien faire fait taire'
(Fait un pet avec la bouche)
J'ai envie de faire ça à la fin de chaque phrase
'Qui aime bien chatie bien.'
Je ne sais pas, non c'est pas un proverbe ça. qui rira bien qui rira le dernier ça veut dire ouai on verra bien à la fin connard
Squeezie traducteur ça donne ça
Donc je pense que c'est 'la vengeance est un plat qui se mange froid'
Hâtez-vous lentement. ça veut dire dépêcher vous mais pas trop
Est ce que ça ressemble à Qui sait peu hâte de le débiter
Rien ne sert de courir, suffit D'savoir viser
Pardon j'ai overwatch dans la tête du coup je dirais rien se sert de courir, il faut partir à point
Tout simplement
La technique c'est juste prendre le proverbe de base et de le donner avec d'autre mot
Par exemple on ne paie jamais trop cher une bonne leçon
ça veut dire mieux vaut mettre le prix pour avoir le truc bien
Que d'avoir plein de fois le truc nul vous avez compris?
la meilleur leçon est celle des exemples
me vois trop dire ça à mes enfants, tu sais Théo (il s'appellera pas Théo)
la meilleur des leçon est celle des exenples aller va a l'école
et n’oublie pas l'école de la vie n'a point de vacances (Théo : ça marche papa)
je dirais la pensée ne fait pas de douane,  l'habit ne fait pas le moine ah on connait tous celle la
il ne suffit pas d'avoir la tenue du na na na pour être comme le na na na
attention Squeezie prof de français
tout le monde a le brevet bon
Théo le chien ne rêve que d'os pour un moine l'abbaye ne faut pas
on voit ici que c'est clairement un piège pour les mecs con qui se dit  et ya moine dans les deux  donc c'est pareil non!
il ne faut pas juger le sac à l'étiquette
c'est ça c'est juste celui la. Alors on paie jamais trop chère un bonne leçon
j'avais faux c'était pas la pensée ne paie pas de douane
c'était à quelque chose le malheur est bon et pour tout le reste on n'avait bon Yééééé
je m’entraîne  à faire tout ça parce que je suis mauvais j'ai des lacune en grammaire
en verbe ect mais en vrai  mon kiff c'est les math mec
et ya tellement  de test  possible
regarder ça c'est le paradis il faut voir ça comme un jeux vidéo le math
calcul mental aller, trouver le chiffre manquant : 55x9
égal 55 x 10 = 550. 550 - 55 = 495
on en parle plus, des questions ?
12 x 3,5. 10 x 3,5 = 35. 2 x 3,5 = 7 + 35 = 42, on y va
87 x ? = 435
x 5
7/13 + 6/13 =
ah ben ça fait 1, ça fait 13/13 ça fait 1
56 : 14 = 4. 10/10 WOUAW
J'aime bien ces tests parce que
c'est ça que j'aime bien car tu n'as pas besoin de connaissance bon à part pour les maths un peu.
It's pure logic
ah c'est génial, si la rue A tourne dans le sens anti-horaire, dans quel sens tourne la roue C ? Ben pareil
une masse de 10kg comprime 2 ressorts identique en série de 10cm. quelle est cette distance si les ressorts sont mis en parallèle ?
ok ... ça change quelque chose s'ils sont comme ça
les ressorts au lieu d'être  comme ça
ah ben il y a plus de résistance, elle comprime  2 ressorts de 10cm donc
là il y en a 20 cm du coup. 5 aller. alors c'est quoi moi j'ai dis 5cm
c'était 2,5 une masse de 10kg comprime
les deux ressorts en série de 10cm donc chaque ressort est comprimé de 5 cm pour une charge de 10 kg.
le calcul du kg dans le premier cas donne k-F..... *surchauffe*
WOOH Wooh il est temps d’arrêter, je donne le signale
d'alarme, ça suffit. eh ben les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo d'humiliation
Est-ce qu'au final, j'ai été humilier ? à vous de me le dire
*Rire*
j’espère que ça vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si c'est le cas
j'avais envie de faire un truc sur mon QI.com, c'est mon petit délire du moment
Voilà ça fait travailler un peu la matière grise, c'est cool
A bientôt tout le monde pour une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regarder porter vous bien. salut, à bientôt !